主人公です
その3年前にだけだってた奥さんから手紙が来たんすよ
この人はて持った
でも村神土に世界に出来たから
何だろうと思って
地元をずらしていいサイレントヒルってもらったらもう
ドット末の方神社行ってください
女
おっ可愛い
を
なぜ前にくるのがたまらん
をじーっ
頭脳とか言って
するか
んだよ
今日は彼女たちの強い
part 2ということで前会長同じ場所からスタートします
前回はああのー a 4ドリー口を二つともで終わったんですけれども
この先はねは絶対モンスターゼルっていう絶対フラで作ってたんですよ
絶対モンスターが来るんですよ
その寝起きで加えた銚子口がちょっと丸いんですけど
どんどんやっていこうと思います
何度コンテンツ賞は
やばいん
入んの
うわぁ
じゃあやるだけ無駄ゲームときわ苑的なんですよねぇ
ただ方飼っ
なんといるってああ
あああああ
[音楽]
マヤバイバイバイバイバイバイん
要はやばいやばい
言われません
を打って攻撃する上てこいつする
交流や工期は攻撃は
ずつじゃないじゃない
で攻撃攻撃
3攻撃できない
えっ命名よっているまーた
えっちゃん日前以降育成のそれこそ
説明書あ
ねえねえ誰だこれはモーセはでは
r 2
グリーン
よしよしよしよします
こいつは一体
モンスターですよ
これを僕の分かります
血が出てるなぁ
なさいん
念には念を入れていっ
うん
そうですねこれはこの人1
死んでいるさっきの怪物に殺されたのと
はずローンスターは無事ね2回ぐらいなんかこう食らったんですけど
んまぁ大丈夫でしょ
抗議の仕方もわかりました
r 2のそうだ
携帯持ってるべ違ったん
ステンプロペなる
ないというか
悪いかなぁ
税務普通
れる提携リズムの変化マイン何かの役に立つかもしれないっていうことで
あさきを通ってたやつですね
小出は r 2を押して構えて
まるで攻撃
あなんか振り方が違った
軽く押すたらこう
なんか
金魚すくいみたいな
長くバローしたらこう
スイカ割りですね
こっ体にすればいく全然わかんないけどまぁ vd が手に入ったんだよ
俺にかかればもう何が出てきてもた部下てますね
間違いないです
イージーだったからかもしれないですねひょっとしたら
ハードモードとかだったら
最初のゾンビで50回打っ
普通に居るやんけー
複数いるさんと末の平和は俺が守る
うわあああああ
たのでがいい
攻撃する
いげん攻撃だああこれが付
大丈夫だから登録の時雌花がながらどうぞ
それ以
rab を自然ツアー
おっ
思いますモースございます
apple ローン
こんなのなんだなぁ
これでシンナー
うっ
上った
思いません
5 a 5以降
強いはペク食らったけど意外といけますね
どこでいけばいいんだろう
がわからないよ
あぁそっぷから康熙帝
道がとずないといってことばっ
ですよね
水が閉ざされている形とばいたしますこれ別にて聞いたを盛っていいよね
ファー死んじゃってごめんなさいと
まずって言っ
どこに行こうかなぁ
ここで火木にはあってほど
カッツストリートとこに行きます
うわぁ
うバイバイ
咳がいるだ俺には分からコレクターうわぁ
みたいな風に盛り込んだかないんだ
普通にするできるだけの時は気がいた時の
ピリピリピリっと音が怖いですね
ん
ません
が
う
そっちか
アパートの鍵果てに入れたんで
後々に入れちゃう
そんなに寄与します
でまぁバートがどこがわかりません
parker パーカーブルームーン
あ目覚めて本当に米
涙目で本当に名古屋ああ
腹これクリアで弾いとか
めっちゃ怖いんだけど
チーズで
なんかアレっぽいともないんですかねぇ
パサートあれじゃほらいっちょサイトアパートメントって書いてあるから
しばらくまっすぐ行ってそこ
あその時には part あるしとりあえずまっすぐ行ってみます
飲むぞ
だができればモンスターを傷つけたくないんですよ
p そうドヤァのラブ&ピースなんでー
あんまりわーすべてよちょっと
あ絶対車の下からくる
なんだろなんでくるものした子いるのうん
ラバーガードピースばいくらと
らぶらぶあんどぴーす
目覚めろ
あー駅のかじゃーん
取れた part 入るんだろう
いやーここじゃないんか
広いで汁いる入れ異例
俺はラバーとピースだー
海津号になれ
あっはぁああガードピース
あっここ入れるんじゃ
ほらずっとだ
あっ箱でしたねここではバーン
そセーブしたい
は絶対中にいる
絶対中にいる
中にいる
曲の前にちょっと周りを確認します
ここがいい
ピッチャー奥からあ
入れないん
ラフ&ピースそうやっぱりねどんな時にも裸眼とピースの基本チャンネルしてダメだと
思うんだ
上から
悪い子サディスティックな奴め
ああいいの踏み絵
無茶フーディ
なんか無いんですかね新しい武器とか
こんな
こんなんかスティック1本坂てないよこの酒
会えだ
はいれっこれはいる
いるよこれはああセーブポイントが
結毛材雪あります今日
あもう
折れたというかこれライフ前ってわかるんだろう
ここのチーズを持っていて結構もうかけられてるんだ奴らねー
体力的なあればやばい気がするんですけど
全然飲めんだろう
エアードリンク付
いうか
だんだんとはなると思います
ハゲに行くしかないか絶対てる
できたりする悩まずだよええ
入ってくんだけどびっくりー
を
俺のおかげか
まったく
これを入れないんだろう別れるなぁ
入りだけないんだよななんか綴りたいけど進み竹内音に聞こえるいる
いるぞ
伊豆
これはわかる
荒野にはいるな
頼むぞいきなりバーンと盾出てきたらこれも本当にバーンズ氏
もうすすめからあ
戻りましょう
たらざくんなよ
4点切返したいけど前が見えない
嫌な予感がするん
ステンスピーカーができないからん
どこ
ぐわあああーーーーっっっ
西はいえばいいらぶあんどぴーすうっ
もうすぐによる
これさぁ怖いわ
[音楽]
あなたいるわ
どっちだ
この野郎
扱い動きですなぁ
よねやったっただった
ふっ
今川家はいません
[拍手]
このなんか寝た状態になったときどうすればいいかわかんないよ
いる
入れたがいるか族モンスター寝たときどうすればいいんだろう
相模攻撃等でいただければ絶対いるわ
いるんだわー
いるんだろう
う
もう食わすの端への笹
うわぁゴーストバスター
ん
このほどこの状態その正体
どうすればいいのかねすごいなっ
すごい動きつしますようおっ
どうするんだろう
届かないと思う
[拍手]
at ドイター
ああ
念には念を入れてもう一発
これがメアリーの分
はい後同分
スイカ割りしてランドに出てる奴も倒せるということです
わかりました
ここにあるにもないですね次の家に
熱っ
体操頃
水な結構謎解きゲームというかこういう探し物は苦手なんですよ
くるか
こいよ
いるんだろう
構えていると思うでは
なあ春菜はなこれ
a
殺すと一発で
一波水と思っ
ここだ
なって気がつきゃ口に入ったらノイズを見たいのが聞こえるん
敵がいないですね
ノイズなにこれ
う
光ってる
壊せと
離れたコースなん
うわぁ夢てよなんだろう
もう
うすごいらしいじゃない
何
[拍手]
おっなぁ
ああああああああおっ
ああ
もう
半田のここまずから急に出てくる本当にやばい
多い中ねー
ずっと待ってるよ何かある
な従兄弟いうとかこれでライトで照らしながら進めるって事か
うまくって良かった
あってここかな
もうないんかなぁ
これとか
動かせ竿じゃないか
せませんちょっと操作はもともとして申し訳ないんですよ
ライザに取り上げていいのかなぁ
多分ないと取るだけだと思いたいです
ちょっと変えるを1回
ライトは大きな収穫ですよ
からこんな見ちゃったっけ
こっち行ってみよっ
全部確かにだけ助かれて闇+か
あっ入れた俺はくっ
選択中の中から来るだろ
を
ダストシュートがある
わーは絶対取ったらなんかクルーザー
重いもの上から落とせば
これフラグだな何か重いものを3つけろって感じですね
ただんせんだけど気になることはない
重い物を見つけなければいけないというわけで重いものを探しに
いきます
ってちょっと索敵にさあぞ1回切ろうかな違憲としたに帰ってセーブしていきます
復刊されたん
あれ違う
勘弁してよああ
治すてるし
ハンドガンの弾
ちょっと帰りに伝わせてきます
あきたきたきたお
をすれば
おっしゃ
はいありがとうございます
じゃあ次であのー洗濯物の部屋に行った何か重いものを食べ探すことになると思う
宜しくお願いします
ビビりすぎてじゃない
まずでねちょっと頑張るんで今回行くは本当によろしくお願いしますよ
じゃ